merci des listes merci de me donner la
parole aujourd'hui on change de nom nous
devenons les républicains mais nous
devons aussi changer profondément ce que
nous sommes
pour reconquérir non seulement nos
territoires les régionales la france en
mais plus encore le coeur des français
pour cela moi je crois au renouveau le
renouveau nous avons fait dans l'eure
c'est le renouveau des pratiques
politiques
le renouveau des idées le renouveau des
candidatures l'uni c'est notre famille
politique avec l'ue dei
alors bien évidemment pour être avoir
cette stratégie de renouveau nous avons
un chef d'equipe bruno le maire qui a
bâti le renouveau avec force et patience
il l'a fait dans l'eure il l'a fait au
sein de sa famille politique et je sais
que demain il sera en corner
public 1 pour le faire votre vie
publique un développement nouveau